look there are movie stars and then
there are movie stars The Rock taking
over Time Square before his box office
face off with Julia Roberts and George
Clooney welcome everybody to
Entertainment Tonight oh yeah there's a
little something for everybody here
today but I booked my ticket to Paradise
with Julia and George who were ready to
kiss and tell with E.T
is kissing each other really ridiculous
I preferred kissing uni didn't have a
beard I have a beard now because I shave
in the morning and it grows by the end
he's so manly he's such a brute yeah the
testosterone it is yeah did you see my
back
[Laughter]
yeah in my mind the dance scene I had a
different version of how I saw you all
grooving
I know you can dance I don't like to
brags you shouldn't really I've Seen Her
Dance too
what are you really like on the Dance
Floor
Unstoppable oh we're gonna get on all
those shows dance dancing with the
Schmucks
what about all cylinder he comes with
his own coffee good let me have a quick
sip of coffee special coffee yeah we'll
have whatever George is drinking these
friends met over 20 years ago they
vacate together their spouses or friends
and while filming their new rom-com they
laughed so much during the kissing scene
it took 80 takes I just got bit by a fly
hang on guys he's a killer this thing
on camera George Clooney yeah I am so
happy to see y'all back together for
what the fifth time now I've been
wondering what male female co-star
combination of let's just say like 80s
90s 2000s has been in more movies than
we have to be true and Adam Adam Maybe
as for George's real-life Love Story
Julia revealed she knew it would happen
for so long people thought you were
going to be a bachelor forever people
thought you thought you thought I didn't
think you knew always a reason to find
the one he has two
yes much heart and soul of like just
truth and goodness to not find the one
so this is nice of you it's true it's
early
is it the woman who changes you or is it
you that change for the woman you know
I'm all walked in the room and I was
clearly done no Julia changed me too she
did yes yes I was a much happier person
ticket to Paradise is in theaters next
Friday
foreign